hello everyone thank you very much for
coming
my name is Katerina and I'm a computer
science student at the University of
Warsaw and I would like to share with
you what I learned last year at my
internship at kodaline okay we have a
problem because you can see their
presentations so I did it together with
another intern Pavel Gilinsky and it
took us three months to to prepare a few
deep learning models for super super
resolution what with this what we did
was search for the available published
solutions using deep learning for single
image super resolution and we managed to
reproduce the results shown in the
papers so who knows what is actually
super resolution ok quite a lot of
people so basically it's a problem when
you want to retrieve a high-resolution
image corresponding to the low
resolution one you have and well we
don't have such good techniques but
still I think the results are quite nice
you'll see in a moment the problem is
hard because it's you post there exist
more than one high resolution images
that correspond to the
lower resolution image okay so first of
all we wanted to reproduce the results
in the papers so we want we need that
metric what we used was weak signal to
noise ratio which is commonly used in
super resolution papers in commonly used
metric which measures the ratio between
the signal strengths when we talk about
images it's the maximal pixel value in
the image the ratio to the noise
strength which is expressed as a miss
quarter or its computed pixel wise okay
so we have the metric we need also some
benchmark that data says and what is
commonly used is the set 5 set 14 and
Berkeley segmentation data set these are
the data says that most papers refer to
computing the average psnr on these
images well especially pay attention to
the butterfly because you when you
search the super resolution papers
you're gonna see this exact butterfly a
lot compared over and over again okay so
when you want to resize the picture
first thing first trick that you can do
which is really easy and which is very
easy you can interpolate between the
pixels the free basics methods are the
nearest neighbor or binding by linear
interpolation well but the results are
not very good because they are just
blurry
no no sharp edges
so what you can do it turns out you can
take just very shallow neural network
trained it and and have much better
results than the bicubic interpolation
this is the first deep learning model
that tackled the super resolution
problem the model takes cut takes as an
input already did big image but in low
quality and it turns out that ok we can
have a good results but it's really hard
to train the network because it is so
simple no regularization of bottners so
that's a lot of problems with this
network what you can think of is maybe
the mean squared error is not the best
thing you want to optimize so M because
it's picture wise it's like for a human
it doesn't matter if you have the sharp
edge two pixels to the left or to the
right but for this psnr metric it really
matters
so maybe you can somehow you can somehow
compare the perception human perception
of an image so who of you is familiar
with perception well loss okay I feel so
the next thing we tried is using
perceptual loss which which is based on
the the idea that if we take a neural
network that is trained for image
classification it has
in its ways encoded the information how
the details of everyday common objects
look like so maybe we can take the
output of some inner layer from from
this network and try to match these
outputs between the our network output
and the target image the high resolution
image the network we used is was VG 616
and below we can see the image from the
from the paper that introduced this idea
in context of the super resolution it
they checked how how we can reconstruct
the image using different layers and you
can see that the further layer the the
more shape actual shapes are lost and
you have the only the the general idea
of the of what's on the image we wanted
to reproduce the paper so we needed to
take the actual actually church
architecture that was in the paper so
here you see that the network is more
complex it uses residual blocks and the
transpose convolution which is layer 4
something which has which is learnable
it's not that we take take the
deterministic interpolation we do the
transport conversion and also you can
see that most of the computation is done
on the lower resolution image and the
Europe sampled the image at the end of
the network
so we achieve something like this with
so it's it's quite good but it has a
really low psnr because because of the
artifacts you will see in a moment but
still I think it looks pretty good
well so how you can justify this method
in a paper has anyone heard of mean
opinion score metric okay so it's a
metric uses this just people's opinion
a lot of people are shown two pictures
and they say okay this one is better
or this one is better and you can score
some some points for these pictures and
you you can show that okay so our our
network performs better in terms of
human perception although the the psnr
metric is a slower okay so here the the
artifacts actually we we got much worse
artifacts that those shown in the parrot
paper but in the paper they they shown
only a few pictures so well we actually
don't know if it's the same thing and
first we surfers think we thought of
okay maybe it's because of the transpose
convolution because it is believed to
create checkerboard artifacts so we we
used another approach to get many better
results and we get better results
battles but we didn't get rid of the
artifacts the other approaches just do a
simple interpolation and then follow it
by convolution so you can see the
artifacts are still there and we think
that
it's probably it's because of the
perceptual loss doesn't pay attention to
such low level say textures another
interesting something Claire is
something called sub pixel convolution
which is very sufficient Intel in terms
of the computation time and it turns out
it's basically the same thing that's us
transpose convolution but you group the
parameters in a different way and it
learns differently and it doesn't
produce the checkerboard artifacts but
still we we used this layer for sapling
and we also get the artifacts from the
perceptual wallows so we believe that
it's because of the perceptual loss
itself okay so I think okay so maybe
we'll switch back to auto optimizing the
Minsk or terror and we took the last
year's state of the art model wishes is
our resonate which has which is much
deeper Network is it has 16 residual
blocks also skip connection also a
parametric row which is similar to lick
your review but the parameter is also
learn the ball they also use this as
newest up something clear the subpixel
convolution and we can see that the
results are all pretty good and as far
as I know the two the best results in
terms of the organizing psnr
so here's what we achieved its you can
see the bicubic interpolation as as this
benchmark which we want to improve and
those free models well all of them are
serious you know in a way unnatural but
we can see that that they have this
sharp edges
okay so what about the textures because
the optimizing means quintero leads to
overly smooth images mmm so one of the
solutions is to use genitive adversarial
networks which again does not score high
psnr because of the textures they they
generate because they don't match
exactly pixel to pixel with the original
image but you can see that this is well
this looks more natural and we did all
of this in a pie chart which was really
really nice experience because when we
started we didn't know anything about
Python and we just went through the
examples on the on the page and it's
turned out that there are already
implemented examples like super
resolution actually with a different
architecture that we had but we had for
free data loader which is well in this
case it's not very it's not a standard
one because it's not a classification
problem but well it's not very
complicated generally the problem of
data sets for this for for super
resolution is it's not hard because we
can take actually any data set with no
labels you'll just down sample the image
you so we have the input and you have
the original image
that you down sampled which is your
target we use the MS cocoa dataset but
actually we could use any other but back
to the fighters you have also the that
pixel shuffle layer which is not trivial
in implementation when you want to do it
by hand but it's already there
so it was very convenient and also in
fighters examples there was this fast
neural style which uses perceptual those
perceptual allows for the style answer
is a little bit more complicated than
for super resolution but well it's it
was in our advantage because we just cut
out some some parts of the code and we
had working perceptual loss okay so
that's that's all thank you for your
attention
okay so questions okay so I would like
to ask you if you apply it your super
resolution models to the real images
taken by two different cameras for
example because usually you take a photo
high resolution photo and degrade it in
various ways then how can you be sure
that you do not learn the inverse
transformation so the way to test it is
to take two cameras one with a high
resolution and one with a low resolution
take two images of the same scene and
try it and it's not usually done in
papers because it's pretty hard so have
you tried it maybe no we didn't what we
did it was trying the model on the noisy
images and well it turned out that the
noise ink is a crucial step you can just
take the super resolution model and and
up sample the image which is noisy
because which it's at some examples the
noise itself I have a question because
you mentioned some datasets that you
used so I assume you downgraded the
images by yourself using some
interpolation yeah for the low
resolution images I assume you used only
one type of interpolation for whole
dataset yes we used by cubic
interpolation for because it preserves
the most information okay because I was
wondering if you could use many
different interpolations in one in one
dataset for example by cubic linear and
Ranchos together yeah actually we did
some experiments on that we used by
cubic and by linear and we also use some
data-orientation like Gaussian blur ink
but well it didn't change much the
results
okay thank you what sizes of images did
you use I mean did you did you reshape
images into one single size or no we
cropped minutes I mean if if we resize
the images well that wouldn't work well
because you will have to resizing z'
which may distort the image somehow we
what we did was random crops we cropped
the image
about 100 per hundred pixels and trying
to network on that any other questions
so I have a question regarding the first
neural network that you show us
so mmm I know that it does not contain
the transposed conversional layer at the
end of the architecture right so I
assume you need to scale the image by
yourself using interpolation right yeah
so if you use the bicubic method and you
or if you train your network with the
bicubic interpolation right so what
happens you've used the image that was
absent with some other type of
interpolation on this network well we
didn't try that it was part of the
method that was described in the paper
okay I mean the network exists of the
bicubic interpolation which is not
learnable and then three layers okay
thank you any other questions okay so
thank you very much for listening
[Applause]